so you're the leaders of China and much
like how the u.s. believed that it was
their destiny to colonize and dominate
North America in the 1800's you believe
that it is your duty to take the throne
from the US and become the world's
greatest superpower and back in the good
old days of Chinese dynasties you just
invade the enemy by force but here's the
problem as much as you hate to admit it
you know that if your military was to go
up against the US military head-on in a
conventional warfare the US would
probably will mix that with all the
other complications that comes with a
modern-day World War and conventional
warfare just doesn't seem like the smart
move and you need to be sneakier you
need to explore other methods of
unconventional warfare in fact you're so
well aware of this problem that two of
your generals even wrote an entire
handbook on it called unrestricted
warfare the goal is not to defeat the
enemy overnight but the slowly tear them
down brick by brick while having your
intentions fly right under their radar
how much of this has to do with China
realizing we cannot go against us when
it comes out to power over military
they'll crush us how much credibility do
you give to that hundred percent hundred
percent and then what do you know in
late November 2019 the shiny new virus
was discovered in Wuhan that most of the
science community agrees has a natural
origin this thing clearly jumped from an
animal species probably the third week
in November to humans we could not have
crafted a virus like this to do what
it's doing I mean we don't have the
creative imagination or the skill set if
somebody said okay I want to find a
virus it'll take out a lot of people
okay this what mother nature does it so
much better than we could ever do it now
at first glance this is pretty bad it's
spreading human to human in a city with
more people than New York you're
probably gonna have to shut down the
area or maybe the entire country if
things get worse but more important than
people dying and stuff this might hurt
your power over the clubs you roll over
now you being a master at this game of
power even though this is a pretty bad
situation that's gonna inevitably damage
your nation where there's a crisis
there's an opportunity so you get
together with your other room
and come up with a brilliant strategy to
make the most out of these tough times
but most importantly to get one brick
closer to your destiny of world
domination you implement this plan a few
months passes by and what do you know
all your competitors economies are at a
devastating standstill your factories an
economy took a rough hit but are back up
and running already
and who are all your competitors
including your arch-nemesis than us
going to for supplies you and here's how
you did it what China's leaders did is a
crime against humanity if it isn't then
there is no such concept in China where
authorities have welded people into
homes to keep them inside or tied people
to post because they didn't wear a face
mask to me these are equivalent to acts
of war on the part of China that when
you look at what they in fact did there
is no other explanation for it other
than that they intentionally wanted this
to spread beyond China now it's
important to realize that your enemy the
u.s. is a worthy opponent after all if
they weren't you would have beaten them
already the u.s. obviously have their
strengths but you also have some very
unique advantages that they'll never be
able to compete on the biggest being
that you don't play by the petty rules
of freedom of speech or freedom of press
you are not pushed around by the people
you rule over unlike the weak leaders in
the US you get things done faster you
also don't have to play by the words of
a petty free market so you can do things
like ban u.s. tech companies subsidize
Chinese first let some companies in but
on the grounds that they share all their
trade secrets with China and many other
tactics on top of that since you've
rigorously control an economy of nearly
1.4 billion people
you've made some powerful Americans
filthy rich turning them into
sympathizers for your regime once this
virus gets out of hand you're more than
happy to use track Honi intact us to
contain the virus that Western
democracies will have our time doing
like welding people's door shut tying
people to pose if they don't wear a face
mask using fish nets to catch offenders
so a disabled boy died because his
father was forced in the Corinth
leaving him alone whatever but most
importantly you have to think of
yourself like the big banks in the u.s.
back in the 2008 recession that were too
big to fail the world depends on you the
world is entangled with your economy
whatever you do
they're not gonna retaliate because if
you fail they fail see in every conflict
every war every negotiation whoever has
the most leverage wins and it's all
these advantages that add up to all the
leverage you have to work with in order
to turn this crisis into your gang and
work with that you do
[Music]
now this virus came up at the perfect
time new in the US were already in an
ever-escalating trade war together the
u.s. was upset with some of your less
than fair business tactics like
constantly stealing their intellectual
property they felt threatened by a rise
of power in the gradual fall of theirs
both of you guys ended up in a race to
ever-increasing tariffs on imports for
products from both countries among other
things and although this trade war is
annoying you don't care you're on a
mission to outshine the US anyway so you
don't have any plans on stopping your
aggression but it would be wise to at
least settle on some kind of agreement
with them to calm them down before they
start getting too aggressive and don't
worry if anything you can always sign
the deal now make it look like you're
cooperating and then worry about whether
or not you want to actually fulfill the
deal in the future in late November
word had already gotten off of the
mainland that there was a virus in Wuhan
by that time you were already in
negotiations with the u.s. to come up
with some kind of truce for a few months
now and are almost at a resolution that
resolution comes on December 13th with
you and Trump announcing an 18-month
phase 1 deal to end this trade war
mayhem
part of that do you include some
laughable stuff like you promised into
by nearly 400 billion dollars in US
products and you promised them to
respect their intellectual property
now obviously you have no intentions of
guaranteeing the buying of 400 billion
dollars in goods or - all of a sudden
stop stealing their intellectual
property like you've been doing for
years on end but if you sign this
agreement and just blatantly break it
it's gonna cause some drama every nation
you do business with is gonna lose a lot
of trust in you by now on December 13th
you've known how dangerous this virus is
for a good four weeks that's four weeks
of testing monitoring and analyzing to
see just how contagious this thing is
while simultaneously suppressing the
knowledge of it so what do you do six
weeks later the trade truce was signed
with an out clause a very clever out
clause that the Chinese made sure was in
there that said if there was any kind of
act of god pandemic
then they didn't have to make good on
what they had committed to buy from the
United States and like a chess
grandmaster two weeks later you
announced the first case of the virus
[Music]
although you already took advantage of
the spares to have an out for that
ridiculous trade deal the real question
is why should only China be crippled by
it but the problem is if other countries
know how contagious this is they'll take
it seriously and be more cautious and
therefore won't get crippled so if you
want to level the playing field
you've got to get them in on this Corona
action so what do you do you form a
government committee on the virus and do
what your beste controlling the
narrative you suppress medical
whistleblowers and now the Chinese
doctor who sounded the alarm a novel
coronavirus has died from the disease he
was so concerned about the government
officials then decided to control the
flow of information by ordering the
doctor to be put back on life-support
despite the fact he was dead and to
change official media reports from death
to in critical condition you get your
buddies in the World Health Organization
involved and stressed that no it doesn't
transfer human to human just stay calm
everything will be all right where wh oh
I'm sure knew that there were how could
they not know about it I mean there are
World Health Organization they've got
doctors you would have seen many more
cases outside China by now the Chinese
government is to be congratulated it has
taken to contain the outbreak but most
importantly like everything else you
share with the world you under report
your infection and DEF statistics so
other countries won't be able to make
heads or tails of what to do a toddler
could tell you based on what happened in
Italy based on what's happened in
Germany and in France and now in the UK
there's no way in a city the size of New
York 11 million people that there were
so few cases it's impossible since
you've been studying this virus behind
closed doors this whole time you know
that the best way for this virus to
spread is through international travel
so obviously Beijing was really working
very hard to prevent countries from
imposing travel restrictions on China
and once you got all this up and running
mother nature will take care of itself
you'll implement the extreme measures to
contain the virus that Western countries
won't be willing to do the virus will
[ __ ] your competitors economies as it
did to your so you're not the only one
suffering and since you had a head start
and you're so innovative where your
quarantine measures you'll be the first
big economy to open back up while
everyone else suffers and the best part
because you have so much leverage
because you're the world's Factory
because every other economy is tied to
yours there will hardly be any
retaliation
[Music]
welcome to the watch the end club I have
tried my very best to make sure that
listen video is as accurate as I can
possibly make it but with new
information coming out every single day
if I happen to like you know say
something wrong in this video please let
me know in the comments below I am a
hundred percent okay with being wrong
all the sources for my videos are always
linked in the video description if you
didn't know that already can we ever
know for sure let these were the real
intentions of the leaders of China of
course not but based on their actions
and letting their actions speak for
themselves this does seem like the most
plausible scenario do you agree with
this video do you think it was trash let
me know in the comments below a lot of
the interviews that you saw in this
video were from the channel value tame
it with Patrick that David and he has
some the best interviews on YouTube in
my opinion which you can also check out
in the sources in the video description
if you've watched this far you're
obviously interested in this channel so
why not consider subscribing like right
now with the red button below I make
video essays like this on the most
controversial and provocative stuff in
the world business every single week and
you should join but before you go I have
a very big announcement that a few of
you have been requesting but before we
get into it I am proud to announce that
you can finally join the Tran mafia
family also known as patreon I was
actually hesitant or starting a patreon
but thanks to these beautiful people
that asked me in the comments below the
Tran crime family is now a thing so if
you've always wanted to join the mob
like me and you want to help this
channels goal of acting as the gateway
drug to curiosity consider becoming a
mafioso you can start out as an
associate a soldier or you can go all in
and start out as a capo or captain this
is for the true supporters that want to
support this channel financially in the
best way possible with the link in the
video description also moving forward I
will only be referred to as dawn trend
or Godfather in fact I will only respond
to comments that refer to me as Don
Trent or Godfather not Jake not Jack but
in all seriousness guys if you're
watching this right now you guys are my
biggest supporters and I appreciate you
guys like more than I can explain in
words I finally found an excuse to wear
a suit in the video so you know here we
are that is all I have for this video
today thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome
I've been Don Tran and I will see you
guys next
[Music]